and a local man is living right in the
middle of the war zone as he works to
house orphans in the southern part of
the country as the invasion continues
the nonprofit is really concerned for
everyone's safety but they're running
out of supplies too sasha loftus joins
us live in the newsroom tonight with
more sasha yes denise and brian the man
i spoke with tonight says he's still in
shock now his non-profit is losing its
funding from the ukrainian government so
he's asking people here at home and
around the world for help
we're in a war zone
it's unbelievable as terror intensifies
across the world las vegas mark davis
shares what it's like to live in ukraine
we just woke up at 5 32 in the morning
to hearing bombs going off it's been
just about 24 hours since russian
president vladimir putin launched a
full-scale invasion across the country
leaving dozens of soldiers and civilians
dead
davis is in mkhilife a city about 300
miles south of the capital kiev running
the non-profit abundance international
that houses over 100 ukrainian orphans
we just want these kids to have a good
start in life he's worried for
everyone's safety but the organization
also relies on government support and as
russia continues its takeover they lose
a huge chunk of their funding we worry
about who's going to write the checks
now because
half of the funding is coming from there
now he and his colleagues are raising
money to keep these kids fed and clothed
we don't know what the future looks like
we don't know what how all these things
are going to happen and they hope others
around the globe can help them get past
what comes next i can't change it all i
can do is try to help bring people
together
davis says the orphanage is quickly
running out of supplies for the children
there if you would like to donate we
have more information on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live in the
newsroom tonight sasha loftis live local
now